hallo ihr lieben ich freue mich und
rahden heutige zur richtig tolles rezept
wir machen eine windbeutel torte allein
schon der name lässt mein herz höher
schlagen
und ja ich beruhige mich ja schon und
das rezept ist auch für anfänger
geeignet wir tricksen ein bisschen aber
auch nicht zu viel und ihr müsst es
nachmachen ich bin mir sicher ich
bekomme wieder so einen ansturm von
tollen fotos und jetzt zeige ich euch
zuallererst die zutaten für unseren
blitz bizkit boden
dafür benötigen wir ein lauwarmes wasser
zucker mehl backpulver und vanillezucker
so die eier sind schon in meiner
küchenmaschinen susanne schüsse ihr
könnt aber auch euer handrührgerät
verwenden dauert dann noch ungefähr zwei
minuten länger weil er das ganze richtig
schön aufschlagen müsst ich die plätze
noch zwei esslöffel lauwarmes wasser mit
hinein das hier ist einfach dass die
eier sich richtig schön voluminös
aufschlagen lassen
[Musik]
nach einer minute auf höchster stufe ist
das ganze zwar schon dick cremig aber
jetzt habe ich den zucker hinzugeben und
jetzt wird es weitere fünf minuten man
richtig schön geschlagen dass die masse
verdoppelt oder sogar verdreifacht wird
[Musik]
so die eier masse ist jetzt so weit als
nächstes vor ruhig backpulver mit mehl
und gibt es in einem schwung mit dazu
das wird jetzt nur noch ganz kurz
eingerührt und dann ist die masse auch
schon fertig den ofen habe ich übrigens
vor gehalts auf 180 grad ober unterhitze
das mehl wird auch nur ganz kurz ein
gearbeitet gerade so 20 sekunden und
jetzt geben wir es ganz in unsere
springform die habe ich mit backpapier
ausgelegt und ich habe heute eine 26 cm
springform genommen das rezept
funktioniert aber auch mit einer 24 cm
springform
[Musik]
so den boden habe ich jetzt noch mal
glatt verstrichen und es ist sehr wenig
denn wir werden ihn gleich nicht
durchschneiden das ist nur unser boden
den 14 im vorgeheizten backofen wie
gesagt 180 grad ober und unterhitze für
16 bis 18 minuten bis er richtig schön
goldbraun ist unser boden ist jetzt
fertig ich hab ihn vollständig auskühlen
lassen und er ist richtig schön soft ich
gebe ihnen jetzt abgedeckt kurz an die
seite und dann machen wir weiter mit der
leckeren creme und da verspricht ihr
euch auch wieder dass die sehr schnell
geht sehr einfach ist also auch wieder
für anfänger super geeignet
wir benötigen kalte schlagsahne
puderzucker außerdem max capone und
creme fraiche oder auch schmandt könnt
ihr gerne setzen
außerdem sahen stand mittel und
vanillezucker wir benötigen windbeutel
dazu sage ich euch später noch was und
ein paar tiefkühl gewähren und wenn ihr
möchtet noch etwas wasser für die tief
gewähren
und diese art von krämpfen liebe ich
total wenn ich länger kennt der weiß
dass wichtig ist ihnen ist nur eine
einzige sache beachten die sachen müssen
direkt aus dem kühlschrank kommen die
schüssel muss kalt sein der schneebesen
auf das muss kalt sein und dann kann
nichts mehr schief geben
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt mascarpone und creme
fraiche in der schüssel
ihr könnt die zutaten noch austauschen
das habe ich vorhin schon erwähnt creme
fraiche könnte durch schmandt ersetzen
mascarpone durch frischkäse hauptsache
die mengen bleiben gleich jetzt gebe ich
noch puderzucker vanille zucker und
sahne in die schüssel und dann wird das
ganz kurz auf niedriger stufe so lange
verriet bis sich die zutaten alle
miteinander verbunden haben
[Musik]
nach einer halben minute sind die
zutaten verbunden und jetzt gegen unsere
sonne stand mittel mit dazu und gehen
dann immer stufen stufe höher und die
queen ist fertig so weit die sahne steif
ist und ihr merkt dass die krise richtig
schön verbunden hat
nach wenigen minuten ist die creme auch
schon fertig und ich weiß jetzt bis zur
weiterverarbeitung in den kühlschrank
geben auch wenn es wirklich nur fünf
minuten sind aber solche krems vor allem
mit solchen zutaten seien etwas capone
und so weiter sollten immer gekühlt
werden
wir kümmern uns jetzt noch um die
himbeeren ich habe jetzt tiefkühlkost
gehen natürlich auch frische und die
sind etwas angetaut ich gebe jetzt noch
für die spätere konsistenz etwas wasser
hin zu 1 2 es dafür könnte auch ganz
beliebig entscheiden und was ihr auch
selber entscheiden können ist wie süß
das ganze werden soll ich habe jetzt
keinen zucker hinzugeben denn ich mag es
inzwischen säuerlicher ist in
kombination mit der süßen creme aber ihr
könnt natürlich auch ein bisschen zucker
hinzufügen
[Musik]
so ihr lieben unser himbeere ist jetzt
fertig und ich hole es noch den boden
die windbeutel und die creme und zu den
windbeutel noch eine ganz kleine
anmerkung mein rezept für selbstgemachte
windbeuteln gibt es bereits auf einem
kanal das verlinkt ich euch hier und in
der infobox ich habe für dieses rezept
fertig gekaufte genommen aus dem
kühlregal
ich finde das gar nicht so schlimm denn
manchmal muss es schnell gehen und das
finde ich total praktisch dass es so
etwas eben gibt und dann nehme ich heute
einfach mal tiefkühl windbeutel so ich
habe mir jetzt meinen tortenboden auf
eine tortenplatte gegeben der
tortenboden ist komplett kalt das ist
ganz wichtig und jetzt gehen wir uns
eine dünne schicht von der creme auf den
tortenboden der dient quasi als kleber
für unsere windbeutel die dann darüber
kommen
[Musik]
die windbeutel sind jetzt drauf jetzt
geben wir mit zwischenschichten etwas
himbeer püree und ich gebe wo die hälfte
braucht die andere hälfte gebe ich
nämlich später über die torte
ihr könnt jetzt das himbeer pure auch
durch ein sieb geben dann habt ihr die
stückchen nicht ich werde es aber erst
später machen also in der torte stört
mich das nicht aber außen herum möchte
ich stückchen nicht haben dann sehe ich
das ganze noch mal und jetzt gehen wir
die creme einmal komplett auf die torte
[Musik]
ich merke die geschichte ist voll oder
ich kann gar nicht aufhören zu grinsen
weil ich weiß wie lecker design wird
also genau das habe ich gar nicht
erwähnt ich mache jetzt heute eine
kuppel torte
ihr könnt es natürlich auch mit einem
back rahmen versehen und dann einfach
ganz normale gerade dort haben aber das
doch langweilig oder
es geht doch auch mal so ein bisschen
raffinierter mit euch alle mit dir und
den
sobald ihr dann mit eurer kuppel form
zufrieden seid gebt ihr das ganze für
eine stunde in den kühlschrank kann das
ganze noch mal richtig schön fest werden
natürlich könnt ihr das auch am vorabend
zu bereiten das ist auch kein problem
ich werde in der zwischenzeit noch mal
meinem büro 7 und dann gebe ich das zum
schluss nur noch drauf so das ist
richtig schön runter läuft stellen wir
das so schön feucht freu mich schon so
bis gleich da ich finde die so schön ich
kann mich nicht satt sehen
das gleiche gefühl hatte ich auch bei
meiner ultimativen geburtstagstorte da
habe ich immer wieder den kühlschrank
aufgemacht um zu gucken wie toll sie
aussieht das video verlinkt auch mal
hier unten in der infobox falls ihr das
noch nicht kennt und jetzt lasse ich
meinen himbeer für die einfach von oben
nochmal runter laufen und dann ist auch
schon fertig
[Musik]
und als topping gebe ich jetzt noch
weiße schoko spinne auf die torte
[Musik]
jetzt ist die windbeutel torte fertig
und kann sofort serviert werden sollte
man ehrlich habe ich euch zu viel
versprochen
nein oder die torte sieht unglaublich
hübsch aus und noch besser sie schmeckt
richtig richtig gut ich freue mich wenn
ihr das ganze nach macht die genauen
mengenangaben schreibe ich euch hier
unten in der infobox schickt mir gerne
wieder eure tollen fotos mit dem hashtag
s kitchen auf instagram dann kann es für
die auch anschauen und ich freue mich
wenn ihr meinen kanal kostenlos
abonniert und verpasst ja auch kein
video mehr
und dann sage ich bis zum nächsten mal
auf gps kitchen tschüss
[Musik]
diese torte haben wir auch schnell ab
gefehlt
die leckere windbeutel torte also macht
den geschmackstest ich habe den
wissenschafter 11